in the book I have this opening story to
make the case which is in Vietnam over
the course of that 10-year War
uh we won almost every major battle we
fought most people don't know that we
actually won most most the battles we've
fought most major battles uh over the
course of those 10 years we lost 58 000
soldiers and Marines they lost uh over 3
million
and so it raises a very interesting
question if you win the battles and you
decimate your enemy how do you lose the
war
and so that's one of the things that got
me interested in in this definition of
the infinite game which is clearly
there's more than one definition of
winning and losing
um uh and in this case America was
fighting with a finite mindset in an
infinite game they were fighting to win
and the Vietnamese were fighting to
survive
and they would fight to the very last
person if necessary and a finite player
who's playing with a finite mindset in
infinite game
where your uh the other players are
playing with the right mindset will
always find themselves in Quagmire
always and the resource the the the
currency of an infinite game is Will and
resources resources obvious and business
it's money War it's money too
um but there's will of the people
remember we left Vietnam because the
will of the people back home yeah and
and will is one of those things that's
very often forgotten companies think
they're strong when they're rich
Enron was rich GE was rich
G is a shadow of its former self you
know uh but what was the will of the
people you know when when when the
foundation shook did they abandon ship
for themselves or did they hunker down
and come together and our nation because
of this obsession with finite mindedness
for the past 30 40 years which means you
know a couple of generations were raised
with that mentality and they were told
that you will excel in at work and in
your career if you if you do this and
now they're the senior Executives
operating under that mentality of that
trade so our nation double we we over
indexed rugged individualism
and we forgot cooperation you know
there's an entire section of the
Bookshop called self-help an industry by
the way that was invented in the 1970s
there's an entire industry there's an
entire section of the Bookshop called
self-help and there's no section in the
Bookshop called help others you know in
politics compromises become a dirty word
and the reality if you if you have been
if you are married or if you have a
relationship
um good luck with with trying to always
be right like compromises listening you
know give and take that's part of the
game for success